or in the what a correct something I
said earlier that meeting is wrapped up
now between the president and Governor
Cuomo actually wrapped up about ten
minutes ago I understand there was no
photo availability or no post tape and
that became available the governor left
we told it was an amicable
discussion that's about all we know so I
apologize for that confusion but all of
this occurs on the same hour that we're
learning right now the United States has
surpassed 800,000 coronavirus cases as
of this hour in New York by the way 215
7125 cases by far the heaviest number of
cases in New York New Jersey is the
distant second and about eighty eight
thousand eight hundred and six but again
these is just the sheer number of cases
and the rate of increase while coming
down it's still going up and that's
something we watch very very closely and
that is a among the reasons why we have
this measure being voted on in the
United States Senate soon to go to the
house that will call for still more
backup to help those affected by this
this shutdown that's been going on
throughout much of the country this is
that four hundred eighty four billion
dollar measure on the Senate expected to
easily get past that and then in the
house but already we've seen
bipartisanship agreement where all the
key players including Nancy Pelosi and
Republican leaders are saying this is
all but a done deal Mike Emanuel has
been following the drama on Capitol Hill
and updates us right now hey Mike well
Neil good afternoon yeah once there's an
agreement between those key players on
Capitol Hill and sign-off from the White
House things tend to move rather quickly
on Capitol Hill it's rare a lot of times
there's plenty of bickering and they
certainly did their share of bickering
over recent days but they've come
together you had initially the
Republicans saying they just wanted to
extend that small business program known
as the Paycheck protection program that
had run out of cash Democrats said there
are other priorities that they wanted to
include so they're gonna get 25 billion
dollars more for testing that is
something that we know that Andrew Cuomo
the governor of New York is speaking
with the president about this afternoon
just wrapped up short time ago but a lot
of concerns about testing how do you
reopen the economy without more vigorous
testing and so that's part of the
package all indications are this
in the next few minutes pass this
measure and then we know a lot of House
lawmakers are in the process of
traveling from their respective
districts back to Capitol Hill to have
at least a quorum for a vote on Thursday
morning it's expected to pass there with
the sign-off of the relevant leaders in
the house but they have to have at least
a quorum of 216 or so members around to
pass it and send it on the president for
his signature Neal you know oh my god um
question on my part but you're used to
them and then one is that this testing
that's included in the legislation
governor cuomo had argued libel eve last
week at this time but that is a federal
government responsibility he later
acquiesced on that to say it was wrong
that the state responsibility now if
it's included in this legislation in
other words to help states with more
testing I guess it becomes a moot point
doesn't it yeah my understanding was
that part of the reason the governor
wanted to come speak face-to-face with
the president rather than talking past
one another in media appearances was to
essentially sort out what does the
federal government going to commit to
doing in terms of greater testing and
what should governor's focus on to do in
terms of greater testing obviously it's
in the president's interest to reopen
New York a key driver of the American
economy
but as you know in the New York City
area people live on top of one another
very closely together and so there are a
lot of people who feel like you can't
open mass transit which is critical in
New York City and the surrounding areas
without knowing whether people have been
tested and whether they are clear or
whether they may be carrying coronavirus
imagine coronavirus spreading around New
York City subway trains and so obviously
they're not there yet and so the
governor wanted to sort out with the
president what's the state's
responsibility what's the feds
responsibility we should get more from
the president when he comes out and does
his daily briefing a little later Neal
all right Mega Man you know thank you
very much